نبدأ بأخبار عاجلة من
سوريا تفيد التقارير بمقتل عدة أشخاص
بعد أن ضرب صاروخ إسرائيلي
مبنى متعدد الطوابق في دمشق
بن ويدمان مراسل سي إن إن آه يتابع هذه القصة
إنه ينضم إلينا الآن من بيروت، مرحبًا
بن، ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عنه  ما
حدث جيدا ما نعرفه قبل ساعات قليلة صباحا
فيكتور كان هناك
انفجار كبير في حي ميس أه
دمشق وهو حي راقي
أه حيث توجد العديد من السفارات الآن
ما رأيناه أه على وسائل الإعلام الحكومية وعلى
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كان هناك  انفجار ضخم
أه عمود ضخم من الدخان أسقط على ما يبدو
مبنى من ثلاثة طوابق الآن
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية السورية تقول أنه كان
موقع غارة جوية إسرائيلية
وتواصلت مع الجيش الإسرائيلي
ولم يعلقوا بعد على ذلك لكننا
نفهم من  وكالة تسنيم للأنباء
هي وكالة أنباء إيرانية شبه رسمية
أه نقلاً عن الحرس الثوري
الإيراني، قلب الحرس الثوري الإسلامي الإيراني،
قوله إن أربعة أعضاء وأربعة مستشارين
من الحرس الثوري الإيراني قتلوا في تلك الضربة
بالإضافة إلى العديد من أفراد
الجيش السوري الآن وفقًا لـ  أه
وكالة أنباء تيس عبارة عن مبنى كان
سكنا لعدة مستشارين عسكريين إيرانيين
في العاصمة السورية الآن هذه
أول غارة جوية إسرائيلية على
دمشق منذ بداية العام
الآن الضربات الإسرائيلية على دمشق وفي
سوريا بشكل عام ليست  غير مألوف أه لكن
ضع في اعتبارك أنه أه قبل بضعة أسابيع فقط في
2 يناير أه هنا في
بيروت كانت هناك غارة جوية إسرائيلية
أه أدت إلى مقتل أحد كبار أعضاء
الجناح العسكري لحماس أه
وبالتالي يبدو أن هذا  قد
يكون على نفس المنوال أه نوع من
الضربة المستهدفة لعضو كبير في
تحالف ما يسمى
بمحور المقاومة وهي غارة على إسرائيل
تشمل سوريا وإيران وحماس
والحسبة والهيس في اليمن بالإضافة إلى
فصائل مسلحة أخرى  في العراق أيضًا،
ليست هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يتم فيها
قصف دمشق من قبل الإسرائيليين ولكن
بالتأكيد هذا يمثل
ضربة كبيرة أه موجهة ضد
أفراد إيرانيين في العاصمة السورية
فيكتور
عمرة